[Music]
it's like the cargo hold there should be
additional Provisions oh oh it is devoid
of Provisions in all seriousness squish
my apologies the human culinary
Creations are exceptionally palatable
astonishing considering I'm supposed to
last the rest of the week I just heard
an unopened package within the confines
of your stomach oh that's gonna go
straight to my drum slash very well
course of action should we take perhaps
forage Provisions from a farmhouse ah a
time-honored tradition agreed are any
additional life forms present negative
only one squish the individual is The
Parting squish
so which of us shall descend first I
volunteer squeeze well I was not
responsible for depleting our food
supply and date squish the
responsibility falls upon you but I
Harbor feelings of uncertainty
interpretation fear not if You Shall
Perish we will simply consume you hey
uncalled for uncalled you will not be
harmed we will maintain visual contact
from our current location just remember
one thing not be detected
I do not know
I'm unsure if I possess the fortitude
yes
respirate
[Music]
this environment
oh
[Applause]
this environment
[Music]
oh this environment is perfection the
human is returning what our parental
units are going to be furious did they
not just depart I forgot a mobile device
I'm uncertain
squish the human is approaching they
will detect your presence that is
acceptable
everything is satisfactory here squish
squish hide behind a tree or a similar
structure a tree a large brown entity
with green components on a success
[Music]
oh
what an Exquisite spacecraft I don't
know do not enter the dwelling
we must take action
[Music]
observe the creepy vehicle come on let
me do it we must have maintained Nuance
squash after this rolling immediately
patience I'm acquiring sustenance
disregard
you're being too nuanced
[Music]
you never let me do anything
your brother just reflect your maturity
God you're so right
[Music]
remarkable they have panko
I hate you
that was very nuanced to me
[Music]
human making the premises immediately
human I get my phone one second do not
retrieve your mobile device
greetings
[Applause]
Earthling
hello
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
did our proximity to Danger was quite
excessive nevertheless our collaborative
efforts were most exemplary we should
engage in such activities again thank
you Jess surely the same siblings
my doorbell cam
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
wow the corridor digital Earthship is so
magnificent oh it can't be look at this
magnificent garments I've read about
them in the Transmissions that the
limited edition media offline t-shirt
they can get on quarter Digital Dot
store yeah you certainly know a lot
about it give it to me oh no it's mine
I'm not wearing it right now but if you
buy one of these shirts you'll be
immediately entered into win one of
these PCS this is a Puget it's worth ten
thousand Earth dollars I'm pretty sure
that's so much money should be for you
maybe I don't know how it works over
there but how does that sound that
sounds amazing squeeze yum yum forget
about the nourishment Supply I've got
great news to tell you
look